The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: Welcome people.
I'm glad to see
you this afternoon.
We finally make our
transition to sound film.
I hope that you endured the
silent era with good spirits.
I think you'll find, as
the semester goes on,
that even some of the
silent films you found less
compelling when you began
will resonate for you
and become more valuable.
And my expectation
is that some of you
will decide, after the fact,
that Keaton and Chaplain,
and perhaps even for some
of you Murnau, presented you
with films that were at least
as memorable as the most
memorable sound films.
But we now move into a
segment of the course
in which every object has more
than merely artifactual a art
value, although the artifactual
value of these remarkable films
is very great.
And as I indicated
earlier in the semester,
my hope is to toggle back
and forth in some ways,
in each of our conversations
about these films
on our syllabus.
To toggle back and
forth between what
we might think of as an
aesthetic perspective, talking
about the qualities
in these texts that
make them artful, memorable,
long lasting, worth
something even beyond
the eras in which they
were created on the one side.
And then on the other side,
more an anthropological kind
of perspective rather
than an aesthetic one.
What do these texts tell
us about the culture
from which they come?
In what ways do the
social, and moral,
and political mythologies
of the society
find complex articulation
in these texts?
So those are the two
sort of perspectives
between which we oscillate.
We now turn to the
kind of film that
emerges after the
advent of sound in 1927.
And we can say that the
period, roughly between 1927,
1928-- when the first
sound films began
to be made-- and the
era into the 1950s,
briefly after the advent of
television, that era is often
thought of as-- often called
by some film historians
the golden age of Hollywood.
And it was in some respects,
maybe in many respects,
a golden age.
It was certainly a
golden age in terms
of the size and loyalty of the
audience for American movies.
And I'll come back
to that in a moment.
What happened of
course in the sound era
was that an industry emerged.
A more neutral term for
the golden age of Hollywood
might just be the studio era.
Because what happened
in the sound era
was a fortification
and extension
of the system that
had already emerged,
and which we've discussed-- and
which David Cook catalogs very
fully in the required reading--
a fortification, an extension
of the system that had
emerged in the silent era.
The mass production
system that was already
in place in the silent era
was perfected and extended.
The principle of the
specialization of labor
became even more complex
and effectively deployed
in the production
of motion pictures.
And in this period, in the
period between 1928 and 1930
for example,
Hollywood spent what
was then a tremendous amount
of money-- $500 million--
in gearing up for the
transition to sound.
It was almost as if silent
films became obsolete
almost instantly.
Almost instantly.
And the famous
line from-- what's
the title of the
first sound film?
The Jazz Singer.
Who's the star?
The theater singer
Al Jolson, right.
And there isn't very much
dialogue in that film,
although there are some
8 interpolated songs.
There's very little synchronous
dialogue, but there's a little.
And one of the most
famous lines-- maybe
the most famous line in the
film-- comes at a certain point
where someone says "You
ain't heard nothing yet",
and the implication is you
ain't seen nothing yet either.
And it is certainly the
case that within three years
there were no sound
films really being made.
As I've suggested earlier, a
comic and still illuminating
perspective on this process
of Hollywood adjusting
to the advent of the
new technology of sound
is dramatized for us in
the wonderful musical
we're going to see in a few
weeks, Singing In The Rain.
So in this era then,
after the advent of sound,
the movies become America's
dominant entertainment form.
And in the period
between 1930 and 1945,
7,500 films are made by
the Hollywood production
system, approximately--
almost exactly in fact--
500 films a year.
Think about the confidence
that this production system
needed to have in its capacity
to get a return on the number
of films that it turned out.
And think about what it meant
that the entire society was now
geared toward this mass
form of entertainment.
We can get some measure of
the tremendous popularity
of the movies, the centrality
that the movies assumed
by the end of the silent
era and into the sound era,
if we think of some numbers.
In 1938, for example,
what we might
think of as the central, the
height, the apex of the studio
system, of the sound
era, there were
a total of 80 million
admissions per week
in the American movies.
That comes to something
like 67% of the population.
Now I'm sure some people
were going to the movies
more than once a week,
so it isn't literally
as if 70% of the
population was attending
the movies every week, but
it's something close to that.
Far more than half
the population
had an intimate, weekly,
habitual relationship
to the movies.
And the form that the
Hollywood system took on
was surely, in
part, a reflection
of this increasingly intimate
and knowledgeable connection
between a mass
audience and the kinds
of movies, the kinds of stories
that Hollywood was pumping out.
Can you think, for example,
why the broad attributes
of the system that I've
already described, can you
think about why those broad
attributes would encourage
the development of what we would
call a system based on stars,
in which, movie stars, the
names of particular actresses
and actresses become so well
known that their names carry
the film.
And people go to
the movies to see
Gable, or Colbert, or whatever
famous performer, famous actor.
And there were
dozens of such films,
in a tiering system
in which there
were great stars at the top,
B level stars below them,
C level actors and
actresses below them.
And the border between those
were somewhat permeable.
And an extraordinary number
of people in the society
were familiar not
only with these stars
and the particular films they
had made, and would follow them
from film to film, but
were all so familiar
with what was a partly
mythological and fictional
story about their private lives
that the Hollywood publicity
system kept pumping out about
the stars and performers.
And what was essentially
created was a kind
of mythological system in which
the stars were literally--
for the audience-- characters
or creatures who are literally
larger than life.
And something, some vestigial
form of that star system
still survives today in the
great celebrity stars, rock
stars, and some of the
great movie stars of today,
but it's on very
different scale.
And the number of such
recognizable figures
is much smaller
today than it was
in the heyday of
the Hollywood era,
when there were dozens and
dozens of actors and actresses
whose entire careers were known
intimately by the audience
and whose work from film
to film was something
that particular
members of the audience
would follow religiously, would
follow as if they were members
of a kind of fan club.
And then the second
aspect of the star system
was-- coupled to it and
linked to it-- was what
we might call a genre system.
What's a genre?
A category or a kind of story.
So the elegy is a poetic
genre, and the western
is a narrative genre.
And as soon as we mention
western, or elegy,
or situation comedy-- to talk
about a dominant television
genre-- as soon as we say
that, a set of expectations
immediately enters
our mind, right?
We know that there are certain
features that westerns have.
We immediately know
when we hear the word
western what historical
era the story is set in.
We know what the
costumes will be like.
We can predict what
kinds of animals
we're likely to see in the film.
We can even, if we know
the western genre well,
we could even predict pretty
accurately what kind of story
we're likely to be told, and
what the rhythms or trajectory
of that story might be.
Not because we know
the particular western,
but because we
know the category.
And every western that
calls itself a western
is in some sense in conversation
with every previous western.
What we're talking
about here, in part,
is a new form of literacy.
Or at least not
exactly a new form,
but a central form of literacy.
A form of literacy that
emerges in popular art
when a mass audience
becomes more and more
knowledgeable about the
conventions, and operations,
and formulas on which
the system depends.
By the middle of the 1930s,
virtually the whole history
of the silent era and
all the new genres that
were elaborated and fulfilling
themselves in the sound era,
were now intimately
known by segments, if not
the entire American audience.
So to come back to
my question, why
would a system that emphasized
the repetition of stars
and the repetition of
genres across experiences
be a particularly appropriate
or useful one for the kind
of system I've described?
What's the answer?
If it's a mass
production system.
The alternative would be, to
clarify my question, why would
we not have a system in
which every movie was
a unique experience?
Did not make gestures toward
a whole class of other stories
to which it belongs in,
which it wants the audience
to compare it.
Or that a series of
stars would emerge,
so that every time
you see a Clark Gable
movie, or a Claudette
Colbert movie,
or a Barbara Stanwyck movie,
you associate those performances
in those films with all
the earlier performances
in which you've see-- why
does that system work?
What's the answer?
All right.
That's right.
Because it familiar,
you know what to expect.
It's a branding.
And in fact, if
you think about it,
if you want people to shell
out money every single week,
you can understand why the
notion that they should
be getting something familiar
might work, might be important.
It's possible that
you could get people
to spend all of a
significant amount of money,
or at least a small
amount of money--
in the early days
admissions we're not
that expensive--
for one experience,
but if you expect them to do
it week after week after week,
it's natural that
you would expect
that the system
that would develop
would offer the audience
certain familiar landmarks.
In other words,
the answer-- and I
think it's a very good
answer-- the answer is
that a mass production
system lends itself
to principles of repetition
and economies of scale.
What's an obvious thing,
if you're a studio
and you make a lot of Westerns,
how can you save money?
Do you have to hire
the horses every time?
Maybe you have your own stable.
Not only that, maybe if you
have a scene of a stampede,
you could use it in
more than one movie,
you don't have to film it again.
And in fact, a lot
of early Westerns
have stock footage
that were put in.
They would film a tremendously
exciting cattle stampede
and they would use it in four
or five different movies that
needed stampedes.
The same with the sets.
They don't have to tear
down the Western town
and rebuild it for every movie.
So in other words, one
could say that there
are economic incentives
that encourage this system.
But this is another example
of that magnificent paradox
that I spoke to
you about earlier
in the term, the paradox that
the crassest of alliances
between commerce and
technology should
be the enabling conditions
of a narrative art.
Why?
Because even though the
origins of these strategies
may very well have been
totally commercial, as they
begin to elaborate
themselves, they inevitably
become more complex.
The audiences begin to
generate expectations.
The people who are
repeating themselves
begin to repeat
themselves with variation.
Even if they never
intended to get better,
they would get better.
And of course some of them
are excellent professionals
and they do want to do
a better and better job.
So what happens is the system
begins to refine itself,
even if it begins in the
crassest of intentions.
Figure out a way to save
money and make as much money
as we can, by
giving the audience
the same thing again and again.
If the audience would buy the
same story over and over again,
no doubt Hollywood
would give it to them.
But of course, they have to
introduce variations just
to make a living.
Just to make people come back.
And then as these variations
begin to elaborate themselves,
something complex and
rich begins to emerge.
And this knowledge
that the audience has
becomes what we might
call a form of literacy,
a form of popular literacy.
So there's much more one
could say about this,
and I'm being very
abrupt and overly brief
about the way this
system elaborated.
Suffice it to say that
there emerged in this era
a series of recognizable
separate categories of movie
making.
Westerns, gangster films,
various forms of comedy,
various forms of social
realism, certain forms
of historical spectacle.
And other smaller genres like
the newspaper picture, which
is a kind of smaller sub genre.
We're going to see one
example of that tonight.
And so that what
I'm trying to do
over the next couple of weeks,
and especially in this week,
is trying to demonstrate
these principles in small,
by talking today especially
about certain aspects
of screwball comedy.
And by placing that
particular central Hollywood
genre in the larger context
of this manufacturing system,
this mythological system
that we've been describing.
One way of explaining
what I'm trying to get out
when I talk about
these stars and genres,
and the purely
commercial origins
of what becomes a rich set
of narrative expectations,
is to say that what I'm
really implicitly dealing with
is a problem.
It will seem less of a
problem to your generation
than it did to
generations earlier.
But it took a long time
before the American Society
began to recognize that the
movies were a signature art
form of American society, and
that if American society was
going to be remembered for
its artistic achievements
in the 20th century,
the movies were going
to be one of the prime instances
of its artistic identity
as a society.
It took a long time for
Americans to recognize this.
In fact, the Europeans
recognized it
before the Americans did.
And one of the fundamental
reasons for that
is that our ideas
about what art is
were inherited notions
that came essentially
from the traditions of
romanticism and modernism,
which lead tremendous
emphasis on pure originality.
On the idea that the work of
art has to be sui generis,
unique to itself.
That it has to grow out only
of the individual genius
of the artist.
Well, this notion of art is
actually a very time-bound one.
It's not really a universal
notion of art at all.
The notion of art that
I want to suggest to you
was a more populist one.
It goes back to Homer and
to the various forms of Epic
Performance, and this
notion of artisan
work-- a communal one,
in which the artist is
a singer or a speaker to the
main parts of the community,
to the whole of the
community, or to a large part
of the community.
And in order to do
that kind of singing,
to do that kind of address,
the singer, the poet,
the storyteller needs to use the
categories and the story forms,
and the language that
is known by the majority
of the community.
The aesthetic for
this kind of art
is an aesthetic of
familiarity, in which meaning
and significance
is generated not
by a shock of total
recognition of everything
in the text being new or
innovative, but by something
else.
By the fact that certain
very familiar strategies
are suddenly very,
very slightly.
And it's the slight
variation from the familiar
that generates the significance.
And I'm going to try to
demonstrate these principles.
In fact, all of
the clips and films
that you're going to see
over the next few weeks--
and especially in today's
viewing and lectures--
are embodiments or
instances of this principle,
as I hope you will see.
What we're talking
about here, to borrow
a phrase from the film
scholar Leo Brody, whose
essay An Aesthetics
of Connection
is required reading
in the course,
we might say that what we're
trying to identify here
is an aesthetics of
connection, in which the links
and connections
amongst different texts
or amongst different
performances, are emphasized.
In which the familiar
is a central element
in artistic experience.
Most people love to
recognize the familiar.
It is not the case
that art always
must continually surprise you.
In fact, art that is
constantly surprising,
that makes no assumptions
that you can share,
or that allude to
or refer to earlier
forms of the experience,
probably such a text
doesn't even exist.
Even if the allusion or
reference to ancestors
is one of antagonism in
which the text is saying
look how different I
am from my ancestors,
it still needs its
ancestors in some way.
So the notion that a text can
be entirely creatively original
is itself a kind of modernist
and romantic fallacy.
In any case, the
artistic principles
on which the Hollywood
film is based
are artistic principles
we could identify
as populist or democratic.
Democratist.
And they're based on the idea
that the familiar and the
every day can be
transmuted into something
more complex by good
performances, by good writing,
by the creation of
a compelling story.
And that meaning is created
not by a single unique creative
act, but essentially
by a conversation
on communal process, in
which a particular perception
or sense of the world is
juxtaposed against older
instances of the same thing.
And by comparison, one learns
something about where one
is in the particular new text.
An Aesthetic of Connection.
It's one measure
of the complexity
and social centrality of the
movies in the 1930s, '40s,
and early '50s, that we
can find in the system
three separate kinds of comedy.
It's a measure of its
maturity, by not just one
but three fairly robust
separate strains of comedy.
And this even excludes musical
comedy, the musical film,
which could be said to be
even yet a fourth strain.
Not just one form
then, but three.
And the form of comedy
we're focusing on today
is screwball comedy,
but I want to say
a word about the
other two strains
to give you at least some sense
of where we're coming from.
The first significant
strain that I
would like to mention to you
is what I call anarchic comedy.
It mobilizes something
that's elemental.
An elemental impulse in many
comedies and maybe in the comic
impulse itself at
some very deep level,
which is an impulse toward
anarchic destruction.
There's always, hidden
in comedy, at least
a kind of skepticism
or suspicion
or hostility toward
the established
and the respectable.
And one form that that
can take in comedies
is a kind of systematic
anarchy, in which
the large respected
structures of a culture
are systematically-- or
sometimes unsystematically--
disabled or dismembered.
And over and over again, in the
comedies of the Marx brothers,
something like this happens.
I won't mention
titles, but there
are a number of titles-- I
think I mentioned one of them
last week or the week
before-- A Night at the Opera,
which concludes with the entire
set of the opera falling apart,
breaking down.
And that kind of
destructive-- there's
another film that
the Marx brothers
made in which they are
on a football team,
and we see one of the things
that Groucho does in that film
is he gets the ball and
he runs the wrong way.
And he scores a touchdown
for the other team,
but then he keeps
running, and he starts
running out of the stadium.
It was a sense that, the
rules of this games are silly,
let's ignore them.
And so this sense of the
dissolution of boundaries
and the anarchic chaos that
follows from the breaking
down of established
categories and edifices
is part of the pleasure of
these Marx brothers' comedy.
And it even extends,
in some way,
to a kind of deconstructive
attitude toward language
itself.
And many times the dialogue
in a Marx brothers film
will go nowhere, it will be
able end up making no sense.
So even language
itself is reduced
to a kind of anarchic
nonsense at times,
in the Marx brothers films.
An even cruder version of this
would be in The Three Stooges.
The Three Stooges are
a version of this kind
of anarchic comedy.
And there's a final
version I should mention,
a rather distinguished
one in it's own way, films
that are associated with
the actor W.C. Fields,
a gravelly voiced comedian
who often portrayed
people who were
half drunk and were
very hostile toward children,
very anti-sentimental.
He would kick children,
or spit at them,
act as if children were
smelly, annoying things who
should get out of his way so we
could keep drinking his scotch,
that sort of thing.
So there was both an
anarchic and a kind
of subversive element
to this kind of comedy.
A second strain of comedy, even
more powerful and artistically
more valuable.
A very, very
interesting one, which
continues to be influential.
Films from this tradition
have been remade recently
in American cinema.
And this is the strain of
comedy we would call worldly,
that other scholars have
called, it's not my label.
And one thing that the
label intends to acknowledge
is that many of these
directors in this tradition
were Europeans.
And they brought a European
attitude, especially
toward sexuality.
They were much more amused than
shocked by sexual shenanigans.
So one measure of
worldly comedy was
it had a more generous
and a less puritanical
attitude toward infidelity,
toward the body itself,
toward sexual allusion,
and sexual by-play.
They still were not explicit
by today's standards.
You didn't see nudity
in these films.
But they were more
open about the fact
that men and women actually
engage in that behavior,
and even sometimes
take pleasure in it.
An acknowledgment that was more
difficult for non-worldly films
to make.
And the central director
of this tradition,
although there were
others, was Ernst Lubitsch.
I put his name up
on the board there.
His dates are 1892 to 1947,
and he made a series of films,
especially in the '30s
through the early '40s, that
are still regarded as classics
of this kind of worldly comedy.
Trouble In Paradise,
Design For Living,
a film called Ninotchka in 1939.
A film called To Be or Not To Be
in 1942, an immensely bold film
in which Jack Benny the comedian
plays an actor who impersonates
Hitler.
The film is set in Berlin, and
he actually plays as a double
of Hitler.
A very bold film, on a
par-- and intellectually,
I think, and artistically
an even more powerful film
than Chaplin's The
Great Dictator,
although it shares
the same ambition.
And these worldly comedies
often told infidelity stories,
or stories, as I've
suggested, that took
a much more benign
and amused attitude
toward our sexual
crimes and misdemeanors.
Both these strains of comedy
are robust and deeply popular
in the era.
But the form of comedy
that I want us to focus on,
that we're centering on in this
week, is the most important
of all of these
strains of comedy,
it's what has come to be
called screwball comedy.
And let me say a few things
about screwball comedy
as a category, describe
it a little bit,
and then I want to
show you two clips that
are intended to illustrate
many of the principles I'm
trying to articulate here.
And we'll come back to
this idea of star and genre
in these clips as well because
those elements are also
at issue or embedded in
what I want you to look at.
Maybe I should've
mentioned, if you
were curious about the later
incarnations of worldly comedy,
I meant to mention that
for example in 1998,
Nora Ephron made a film
called You've Got Mail.
How many of you have seen it?
At least a couple.
That's a remake of one
of Lubitsch's films.
And in fact, the Lubitsch
film, A Shop Around The Corner,
is a much more wonderful film.
And it's a measure,
I think, in part
of the power and authority
of Lubitsch's imagination
and the elegance of
his comedies that they
continue to inspire
imitation in that way.
What screwball comedy is,
in some ways, a distinctive,
a signature form
of American movies.
It's a unique equation of
Hollywood in the depression
years.
It's derived in part from
Broadway farces of the 1920's,
and also from the slap
stick physical comedy
of the silent era.
It's a kind of
marriage or hybrid.
And remember--
we've already said
this but let me remind you--
one measure of a mature medium
or of a medium that's coming
into maturity-- an expressive
medium, a communications
medium-- one
measure of its maturity or
of its emerging maturity
is that forms that used to be
thought to be separate, marry.
Become hybridized.
One of the things I was
suggesting about Chaplin's work
is it suggests a new
maturity in the film,
in the cinema as an
institution because it's
marrying comedy and
melodrama, because Chaplin
bring seriousness into comedy.
He slows it down, it's not
merely just slapstick anymore,
it's also
psychologically resonant.
Not only can it make you
laugh, it can move you.
That marriage or hybridization
of two essentially
separate forms--
melodrama, comedy--
makes for a richer film.
I'm saying the same kind of
thing about this particular
form of comedy, this
merging of ancestor forms,
of the slapstick comedy
of the silent era--
and of course the slapstick
comedy of the silent era has
its ancestors in
stage slapstick--
and fast dialogue and witty
repartee that was especially
characteristic of a
series of Broadway farces,
made in 19-teens and the 1920's.
But the particular
historical moment
in which this form
emerges is also
a shaping factor in
the kind of comedy
and the subject matter
of these comedies.
The key qualities
of screwball comedy
were a kind of irreverent
humor, something
of the anarchic
subversive skepticism
that's characteristic of
many comic perspectives,
coupled with very fast
paced vernacular dialogue.
One way to think
about screwball comedy
is to say it's one
of the first forms,
along with singing
movies, movies that
have singing in-- I don't
want to call the musicals yet
because sometimes they
weren't fully musicals,
although musicals
do emerge at a very
early time-- but any movie
that had singing in it,
like some westerns.
Early western's
had singing in it.
Why?
Because sound had just
come in, it was a novelty.
The screwball comedy
is one of the forms
that exploits sound in a really
expressive and powerful way,
compelling way, because
it's full of dialogue.
It's full of witty, rapid
dialogue, most often arguments
or conflicts or quarrels
between men and women,
dramatizing certain kinds
of conflicts of gender
in the course of the film.
So, key qualities.
Irreverent humor, a kind of
vernacular fast-paced dialogue,
a fast physical pace as
well, full of slapstick.
So a physical quick pace
and a verbal quick pace
that are often in competition
with each other to see which
can be more irreverent and
quick and fast and abrupt.
Eccentric, often high born
characters, who are made fun of
and mocked.
A lot of the
screwball comedy deals
with the upper social
orders, but they're
seen as clownish or
foolish in some way.
And in many screwball comedies,
the wealthy characters
need to be rescued
by their servants.
It's a very modest
form of class warfare,
in which-- again, remember it's
the American capitalist system
that's making these
stories, so we're not
going to have a
Marxist comedy that
says that the government should
be overthrown by violence--
but the comedy is constrained
in certain ways, what
the story's able to say, what
the films are able to say.
This is a matter to which
I'll return tonight and talk
a little bit more fully about
the ideological and political
limits that are imposed
on the Hollywood system
because it has to
appeal to everyone.
I think what I have to say will
clarify these questions in ways
that you'll find very helpful.
But for now, let's stick
with screwball comedy itself.
These high born
characters then, they're
criticized and seen as
clownish, but they're never
seen as morally evil in
the way that a Marxist
or a social historian
might regard them.
The stories are often very
deeply improbable ones
that are set among the
irresponsible wealthy,
the irresponsibly
wealthy people.
Often the aristocrats are very
spoiled and hard drinking.
In one of the most famous of
these, a film made in 1937
titled My Man Godfrey, directed
by Gregory La Cava, Carole
Lombard and William
Powell, two of the central
to screwball comedy
performers, are the stars.
And there is a scene in a
shantytown by the river,
in which the poor are located.
And the film seems
to make some sort
of an acknowledgement of the
fact that the poor are here.
It's acknowledging the
horrors of the Depression.
But it solves the horrors
of the Depression in the end
by having the wealthy people
build a nightclub on the river
banks to create employment
for all the unemployed.
And it's a very imposed-- and
rather foolish in some sense--
happy ending.
So that film
acknowledges more fully
than some screwball comedies
the actual existence
of shanty towns and places where
homeless people, or people who
have to live under canvas live.
Many screwball comedies
didn't even go that far,
but it solves the social
problem in a characteristically
mythological and magical,
socially incredible way.
Another aspect of these films
is that they foregrounded women,
and this is a very
important aspect of it.
This is partly a function of
the fact that in the 1920s,
the era of the flappers,
a new kind of sexually
liberated woman
begins to appear.
Some of that is an
outgrowth of the fact that,
during the First World War
when so many American men were
in uniform, women got new
jobs and were able to work,
enter the workforce
for the first time.
And that created
moments of freedom
for women that had never existed
in American society before.
And some of that is reflected
in screwball comedy,
and in other films as well,
but especially in the screwball
comedies of the era.
So it foregrounds women.
And it shows women who often
have a great deal more energy
and freedom than the females
in other films of the era.
Very often in these
films, marriage
is seen for the first time
as a partnership of equals.
And as you'll see in It
Happened One Night, that's
the ideal of marriage that's
dramatized in that film,
one of the two
screwball comedies
we'll be looking
at this evening.
So these films also reflected
the social disorientation
of the '30s, the uncertain
values that were represented
during the Depression.
The fear, in some sense, that
the culture was breaking down
or that the fabric of society
was tearing in some ways.
And so these films
were ironically
simultaneously escapist, because
they were screwball comedies
and they did zany
things, and they often
had ridiculous or improbable
plots and improbable
characters, and yet
at the same time
the anxiety that
they also dramatize,
the anxiety of things falling
apart, of the center not
holding, of a kind
danger to the established
structures and belief systems
of the society, underlay
even the most apparently
escapist of these films.
So there's a subtext
of strong women,
of quarreling and
manipulative men.
And especially, of
course, one of the things
this dramatized for
us were intelligent
and witty women, like
Katharine Hepburn
in Bringing Up
Baby, or Claudette
Colbert in the film you're
going to see tonight,
It Happened One Night,
or Rosalind Russell,
in the second screwball comedy
you're going to see tonight,
His Girl Friday.
And then finally, implicit
in what I've been saying
is that there are
implicit in these stories,
sometimes rising to
the surface, sometimes
just beneath the
surface, but there
are as a kind of
hint or anxiety,
are what we might call first
some form of class conflict.
Some sense that the class
structure of the United States
is a problem, that
the Depression is
causing difficulties.
And second, a form
of sexual warfare,
in which the inequality
between men and women,
and the unequal relations
that men and women have
in the society are put in
question, are quarreled with.
In some sense, even mocked.
And in many of these films, the
actress is the dominant figure
and the male character
is the secondary figure.
And even in some of the films
where the male characters are
even more powerful, the best one
can say is that they're equals.
And that in itself, regardless
of what the plot does,
was in some sense, not
exactly revolutionary,
but transformative.
Potentially transformative.
Well, what I want to do
with the time I have left
is show you two
clips, and they're
intended to dramatize
many of the principles
I've been talking about.
So let me rehearse them
very quickly to you.
I'm going to show you two clips
from two separate screwball
comedies.
One, directed by Preston Sturges
in 1941, called The Lady Eve.
A second, directed
by Howard Hawks,
the director of the
second film we're
going to see tonight,
Ball of Fire.
Hawks is probably, of all
the directors, the one most
identified with
screwball comedy,
although as you'll see
tonight when I talk a bit more
about him, he was a master
of other genres as well.
But the reason I want you
look at these two clips
is-- I have multiple reasons.
It's the multiplicity
principle in criticism.
What I want you to recognize
as you're looking at this,
is first the power
of the star system.
Because here's Barbara Stanwyck.
At this point in
her career, she's
one of the dominant female
stars in the society, one
of the biggest moneymakers
in the society.
And here we see her in two films
that are in the same genre.
Two different versions
of screwball comedy.
As you're watching,
think about the way
in which the persona
that she established,
the kind of character she
stood for in film to film,
is both stable
but also changing.
That is to say, the
pleasure you take
in watching the two different
versions of Stanwyck
is an embodiment of the
principle I was talking about
before, when I said that we
need an aesthetic of connection.
We need to recognize
that it's the familiar,
rather than the completely
strange and new,
that can generate
profound, complex sentence
of artistic achievement.
Because the Stanwyck we
see in these two films
is in many ways a radically
different character,
but we can also see
certain continuities
across her characters.
And we can take pleasure both
in what is the same about her,
but even more we can take
pleasure in the variations
she's working on this persona.
So one of things
that is embedded here
is a notion of acting that
emerges in the studio era that
establishes American
acting as something
different from the classical
British theory of what
an actor is.
The classical British
theory of what an actor is
is that the actor submerges
herself in her role
and becomes indistinguishable
from the role.
And that you shouldn't
even be able to recognize
the actor from role to role.
The American system that emerges
from Hollywood and from movies
is an opposite one,
in which you are not
only are you supposed
to recognize the actor,
you're supposed to take
pleasure in the way
the actor-- it's
not really Barbara
Stanwyck but the character that
Stanwyck plays, the persona
Stanwyck established is in
film after film after film,
how does that persona evolve?
Change in nuances, when
that persona is presented
with different
sets of questions,
different sets of problems.
And what you can
feel-- and this isn't
just true of the
actresses of course,
it's even truer for the male
stars who had more freedom,
there were more rules
available to them.
So people who are interested in
Clark Gable or Humphrey Bogart
could watch these actors across
a range of films, each time
not getting the same
experience, but watching
a variation on the persona
that the actor was setting up.
So a new idea of acting,
a different conception
of what an actors job might be
and of how the audience might
have a kind of
literacy in performance
that would enhance
and complicate
their sense of any
individual performance,
emerges in this era as well.
And the Stanwyck clips
demonstrate that.
The second thing
I want you to see,
again, same principle,
having to do with screwball
comedy itself.
Here are two different
screwball comedies,
look at the differences in tone.
They belong to
the same genre, we
can feel how much they
belong to the same category,
but also how much variation
there is between them.
So the point is, it isn't
a simple form of repetition
at all.
It's a form of very complex
elaboration and complication,
in which the relation between
one text in the category
and another text is far
more complex, artistically
satisfying, and
rich than we might
imagine if we described this
system in too abstract a way.
So here's the first
scene from The Lady Eve.
And let me set the scene.
In this scene, Barbara
Stanwyck plays a con lady.
She's on a ship loaded
with wealthy aristocrats,
wealthy American businessmen,
and she and her partner
are trying to goal
them out of money.
And she's sitting
at dinner trying
to pick out a guy that is
going to become her mark,
played by the great American
comic and serious actor
Henry Fonda.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
DAVID THORBURN:
He's very wealthy.
Everybody knows
he's very wealthy.
He's the son of a beer
magnate, an ale magnate.
He's sitting down in the dining
hall of this cruise ship.
And all the fortune
hunting women
who are there wanting to marry
rich men are staring at him.
-Not good enough.
-What did you say?
-I said they're not
good enough for him.
Every Jane is giving
him the thermometer,
and he feels they're
just a waste of time.
He's returning to his book,
he's deeply immersed in it.
He sees no one except--
watch his head turn
when that kid goes by.
Won't do you any good, dear.
He's a bookworm, but
swing them anyway.
Oh, now how about this one?
How would you like that
hanging on your Christmas tree?
Oh, you wouldn't?
Well, what is your
weakness brother?
DAVID THORBURN: So
Stanwyck has become
the narrator of this scene.
But see what intelligence
she shows, what knowledge.
-Look at that girl
over to his left.
Look over to your
left, bookworm.
There's a girl pining for you.
A little further.
Just a little further.
There.
Wasn't that worth looking for?
See those nice store
teeth, all beaming at you.
Well, she recognises you.
She up, she's down, she
can't make up her mind.
She's up again.
DAVID THORBURN: I hope
you see how brilliant this
is because look
in her hand here,
we're looking at this
through the mirror
as she's narrating it to us.
-Went to manual training
school with in Louisville?
Oh, you're not?
Well, you certainly
look exactly like him,
it's certainly a
remarkable resemblance.
But if you're not going
to ask me to sit down,
I suppose you're not going
to ask me to sit down.
I'm very sorry, I
certainly hope I
haven't caused you any
embarrassment, you so-and-so.
I wonder if my
tie's on straight.
I certainly upset them, don't I?
Now who else is after me.
Ah, the lady champion wrestler.
Wouldn't she make a houseful?
Oh, you don't like her either?
Well, what are going
to do about it?
Oh, you just can't
stand it anymore.
You're leaving, these
women don't give you
a moment's peace, do they?
Well, go ahead.
Go sulk in your cabin.
Go soak your head
and see if I care.
-Very sorry, sir.
-Why don't you look
where you're going?
-Why don't I look?
-Look what you did to my shoe,
you knocked the heel off.
-Oh, I did?
Well, I'm certainly sorry.
-You did, and you can just
take me right down to my cabin
for another pair of slippers.
-Oh, well certainly.
It's the least I can do.
By the way, my name's Pike.
-Oh, everybody knows that.
Nobody's talking
about anything else.
This is my father
Colonel Harrington.
My name is Gene,
it's really Eugenia.
Come on.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID THORBURN: I
hope you recognize
the tremendous
intelligence and wit that
was embedded in that dialogue.
That was a little too low.
What is revealed
about that character,
dramatized about that character,
in that opening scene,
tells us almost everything
we need to know about her.
Not everything, but
almost everything.
And you can feel
the energy, the wit.
And of course, who's in
control of that scene?
Not the man, but the woman.
Now let's look at another
scene from Howard Hawks
film, Ball of Fire.
The basic situation is Gary
Cooper, the man in the middle
here, this fellow Gary
Cooper is the head
of a consortium of
scholars who are compiling
a dictionary of the
English language,
with special emphasis on
colloquial or slang English.
And earlier in the film, Gary
Cooper went to a nightclub.
And he saw the Barbara Stanwyck
character, who is actually
the mistress of a mob boss,
do a song and dance number.
He spoke to her,
he interviewed her,
and he became very excited
by what she represented.
By the linguistic resources,
the verbal realities
of the American language
that he'd been oblivious to.
And he wants her to
contribute to his project.
She's not interested.
When she shows up at the lair
of the men of the scholars,
when she invades the
nest of scholars,
she does it because--
although you don't know that
from seeing this clip,
but viewers of the film
would know it-- because
she's really on the run.
She's afraid that her
boyfriend, the mob boss,
is going to bump her off.
So she needs to hide out.
And that's really
why she's come here.
All right.
So here is this scene
from Ball of Fire.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Have I missed anything?
-No, I was just
about to explain.
You see the word
puss means face.
As for instance, sour
puss, pickle puss.
Sugar puss implies a certain
sweetness in her appearance.
-Never mind the
etymology, was she--
-Was she blonde or brunette?
-Yes, which?
-That I don't know,
I didn't notice.
But her vocabulary, even
an ordinary conversation--
-Oh, you spoke to her?
-Yes.
In her dressing room--
-In her dressing room?
-Backstage?
-Yes.
Unfortunately, she disclaimed
any interest in our project,
in words so bizarre they
made my mouth water.
Shove in your
clutch, for instance.
-It's amazing.
-Potts, could you tell us,
what was it like backstage?
-Very vivacious, I imagine.
-Perhaps ballerinas giggling
up and down iron stair cases?
-Possibly wearing tights?
DAVID THORBURN: I
hope you're picking up
the subtext that these
old men are revealing.
-It's getting a
bit late gentlemen.
Perhaps we had
better get to bed.
-Someday I'll tell
you my experiences
with a young actress
named Lillian Russel.
-Did you know her?
-I stood in the snow
four hours to get--
-Is that our doorbell?
But it's 12:25!
-Oh, must be the statistics
on San Salvador saltpeter.
I asked for it to be sent--
DAVID THORBURN: Did anyone
pick up on the joke there?
Why is there a joke in
reference to saltpeter?
It's used in the army to keep
men from getting too horny.
It damps down your
sexual energies,
and he's writing an
article about saltpeter.
-Hi-DE-ho!
Don't tell me I'm
too late for class.
-Oh my goodness gracious me.
-What is that?
DAVID THORBURN: I don't
know what scholar came up
with this brilliant
description, but there's
a kind of convention
now among Capra's fans,
and fans of this movie, to refer
to this scene as the Snow White
and Seven Dwarfs scene.
-Those are my colleagues.
-Oh!
-I must apologize for
their lack of costume.
-Oh, that's all right professor.
-I haven't got my tie on.
-Oh, you know once I watched
my big brother shave.
-Would you come in?
-Why not?
-Frankly, your coming here
was the last thing I expected.
Your no was so explicit.
-Well, I got thinking
it over, and I
said to myself, who am I
to give science the brush?
-And I take it
you've reconsidered?
-Yeah, that's the big idea.
-Oh dear, oh dear.
-Look out.
-That was Professor Oddly.
-Anymore of them around?
-I hope not.
-Hey, who decorated this place?
The mug that shot Lincoln?
-This is our work room.
The living quarters
are upstairs.
-Whee, that's a lot of books.
All of them different?
-I trust.
May I have your coat?
-Yeah, thanks.
Oh, Greek philosophy.
I've got a set like this
with a radio inside.
-Are you sure you
don't want your coat?
-No, I'm fine.
Except I've got a
run in this stocking.
Well how do we start, professor?
You see, this is the
first time anybody
has moved in on
my brain Have you
got some kind of a machine, an
x-ray or a vacuum cleaner maybe
that's out the words you want?
What's your method, professor?
-Well, it's quite simple.
If you'll be here tomorrow
morning, not later than 9:30--
-Tomorrow morning?
-Well, yes.
I've arranged a
roundtable discussion
with a few people of
various backgrounds.
-You, you don't think we could
begin the begin right now?
-Well, it's nearly
one o'clock Miss--
-Oh, fool professor.
Let's get ourselves a couple of
drinks, light the fire maybe,
and you can start
working on me right way.
-I wouldn't think of imposing
upon you at this hour.
-Listen, I figured
I'm working all night.
-Any hasty, random
discussion would
be of no scientific value.
You see, I have to have my
notes thoroughly prepared
for the seminar tomorrow.
-OK.
Where do I sleep?
-I don't know,
where do you live?
-Up on riverside, but
I'm going to sleep here.
-Here?
Oh, you don't
understand Ms. O'Shea.
We're all bachelors, with the
exception of Professor Oddly
who is a widower.
Why, no woman ever--
even Ms Bragg,
who takes care of our needs--
goes home every night at 7:30.
-If you want me tomorrow
morning at 9:30--
-Oh, I do Ms. O'Shea.
But even the most free-thinking
people must respect the--
-All right.
Feel that.
Go on, feel that foot.
OK, tootsie bell,
what do you say?
-It's cold.
-It's cold and it's wet.
Now, come here.
Come here.
Closer.
Oh, come on, give.
Hello kids.
Look down my throat.
Go on, look down.
All right. [MUMBLING]
-I don't know what to look for.
-There is possibly
a slight rosiness
in the laryngeal region.
-Slight rosiness?
It is as red as the Daily
Worker and just as sore.
Who are you?
DAVID THORBURN:
The Daily Worker.
Red as the Daily Worker.
Did you get that?
No?
The Daily Worker is a
communist newspaper,
so when she says "it's as
red as The Daily Worker,
she's making a rather
witty joke, especially
for a gunman's maul.
-Oh.
-Professor Robinson, Law.
Professor--
-Ah, ah, ah.
Not so fast.
Just let it creep up on me.
I'll get to know them.
Come here physiology, for
all I know I've got a fever.
Feel.
-It's possible.
-Certainly.
And he wants to throw
me out on my tin.
There'll be no 9:30 for me if
you make me go out in the rain
now.
-Naturally not.
-With the streets cold, and the
subway hot and full of germs?
-Oh.
I'm a pushover
for streptococcus.
Can I have this now, kid?
-We'll call you a
taxi, and furnish you
with woolen socks
and warm slippers.
-Really, I don't
understand you Potts.
Why take chance with
valuable material?
-Think of your article, Potts.
-See.
They get the point.
-If I might venture
a suggestion,
why couldn't the young
lady sleep in my room?
-Professor Peagram!
-I can bunk in with
Professor Robinson,
I sometimes do when
there's an electric storm.
-Yes, he's afraid of thunder.
-Well then, it's all settled.
Well, I guess I'll turn in.
Can I have my coat?
-Thank you.
Hi-DE-ho, fella!
-I'll show you to my room.
-Yes, we all will.
-I know where my own
room is, thank you,
without any help from you.
-I'll find it, don't bother.
Just rough out the directions.
-The top of the stairs, and
the third door on the left.
-Gentlemen.
Just a moment, please.
Gentlemen, this is
all highly irregular.
What if this should come to the
attention of the foundation?
And what about Ms.
Bragg tomorrow?
-What are you talking about?
This is research, isn't it?
-Yes.
-Certainly.
Who was that guy
that learned so much
from watching an apple drop?
-Isaac Newton, 1642 to
1727, the law of gravity.
Yeah, that's him.
And I want you to look at me as
another apple, Professor Potts.
Just another apple.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID THORBURN: All right.
So you can get an idea not
only for how richly comic
these films can be, but
also how rich the subtext,
the sexual subtext can become.
Even though, of
course, as you all
should know if you've
been reading Cook,
there was a production
code in force after 1934,
and there were all kinds of
very elaborate rules imposed
on American movies.
A form of self censorship
because the movies feared
censorship from the
government, so they came up
with their own system.
And until sometime
in the, I guess
it was the 1960's, the code
held and it had all kinds
of ridiculous elements in it.
One of the primary ones that
people always laugh about,
rightly I think, is that if
it showed a woman on a bed,
at least one of her feet
had to be on the floor.
You couldn't show a woman lying
with both feet on the bed,
it was too suggestive.
But you can see how
clever filmmakers
and powerful performers
were able to make
a mockery of those
kinds of constraints,
because subtle and complex
and witty films are
able to do many,
many things that
are in a suggestive way,
that keep them from crossing
the boundaries set
up by the censors,
but nonetheless have a
powerful energy and sexuality.
So the similarities
between those two scenes,
but also the differences
between them,
tell you something
about the way in which
the aesthetic of connection,
this aesthetic of familiarity,
this popular aesthetic
operated in Hollywood movies.